hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast and
just checking in on you what's going on
how are you how's it going for you
well i have mixed emotions today all
right cause today is my
53rd birthday for me
it's my [ __ ] 53rd birthday for
me
i have more years than freckles on my
face
what the [ __ ] are you gonna do um
yeah it's my birthday today i already
had an unbelievable birthday
i already had an unbelievable do i get
rid of that do i let's do the sadness
before the amazement uh unfortunately
my boston bruins uh
[Music]
i mean they just lost three in a row in
the series to the
amazing new york islanders i mean
i'd love to [ __ ] [ __ ] about
something but they just
[ __ ] you know we were up two games to
one we won the first one then they won
the second one in overtime and then
marshawn
and always showing up [ __ ] won the
the third one in overtime
and it was feeling like we were gonna
tip it in our favor
or i felt like the very least that i
just felt they were really evenly
matched at least i did before those last
three games
and i just thought like okay this is
gonna be one of these back and forth
back and forth
but it was crucial to win the first one
because i don't see either one of these
teams blowing
a series lead how wrong was i we were up
two games to one
and then they just ran the table and uh
whatever they figured out i don't know
hockey that
well enough i know that mark uh matthew
uh i don't know how to say barzell
barzl barzell i don't know it's a-l it's
[ __ ] weird that guy just [ __ ] i
don't know
he just took it to another level and was
a pain in the ass and pissed people off
and got a [ __ ] lady bank candidate to
spare him in the balls and then he'd be
back on the ice two seconds later
setting up somebody for a [ __ ] power
play goal if he didn't score himself
um that kid 29 brock nelson was
everywhere on defense and uh
barlaam off their goalie he just
i don't know he was just always in
position i will say that
because everybody was like oh my god
he's playing unbelievable i didn't see
an unbelievable save the [ __ ] guy was
just where we were
he was never you know quick pass and all
this didn't seem like that you know all
of a sudden he's
rushing to the other post and he just
doesn't get there in time or made a
great save he just was [ __ ] the guy
he was just there oh wait
remember that reservoir dogs you know
alarm goes off you got five to seven
minutes but man those cops they were
just there
already all loaded for bear
so um but i gotta tell you man
um as much as it sucked that my team
lost it was fun to see islander fans
going crazy again and that took me back
to
uh my childhood when they won those four
in a row
and just how loud that place got and
i'll tell you something else which is
[ __ ] crazy is they cut to the crowd
two games ago
and um it looked like a crowd shot from
the late 80s i guess
is the mullet back i think the mullet's
back
there was a bunch of people in that
crowd that looked like
if they didn't own a monta monte carlo
ss
that was their dream car so i kind of
got a kick out of that it reminded me of
uh
some of the shows i did out in governors
way back in the day
so congratulations to them great fan
base and all that
good luck i'll be pulling for you in the
next round nothing against tampa bay
because i love that franchise too but
like
you know they won it last year um
you know either way it'll be cool either
way it will be cool because
uh you know if tampa goes to win it
again then they won two cups in a
uh a super bowl in the last year and
they start to make their mark as
you know their their case of being the
next title town now they'll call
themselves title town
because they only want three but i mean
you know that's what newer cities do
the benchmark uh is boston
okay it really is and every other town
can go [ __ ] themselves because
we were title town for two [ __ ]
decades when there was 30 teams in all
four sports
not this [ __ ] uh mullerian curly
horse [ __ ] from back of the [ __ ] day
that's my argument but anyway plowing
ahead and how about your [ __ ]
montreal canadiens
jesus christ mopping the [ __ ] floor
with the winnipeg jets
i mean they just the montreal canadiens
i don't know if you realize this have
won
seven playoff games in a row
and are looking like they have the magic
that brought them to their last cup in
1993 when they were not a a
um they were not a favorite and all of a
sudden
they just i don't know of course they
had patrick wah before they
booed him out of town um
yeah unbelievable that's what kant's
montreal fans are [ __ ] 1993
with no team that guy [ __ ] just stops
every puck and you guys win
[ __ ] in overtime in three years three
years you give a [ __ ] day you bow him
out of town
oh god i love bringing that up and i
always will
until you win your next cup which might
be you're only eight games away but
you're going up
is it gonna be the vegas knights did
they beat the abs who were looking like
[ __ ] world beaters
i was just out in [ __ ] uh colorado at
red rocks checking that place out
because i might film a little something
there
and uh somebody was saying like yeah
yeah the abs are gonna [ __ ]
we're gonna [ __ ] wipe your [ __ ]
ass jacks they were talking all this
[ __ ] i was like yeah you guys look great
let's see what happened vegas knights
you know what i just realized is that
also mean could be like n-i-g-h-t
all right the series is 3-2
oh boy oh god this is a birthday wish
do i really hit the cl i can't hit
decline this is my nephew
and i did hit decline so [ __ ] funny
and i ended up hitting decline by
accident how the [ __ ] did i just do this
like i don't want to hit the client and
i just hit the climb oh
no that's worse than not picking up i
just hit the client well i got to
[ __ ] stick with it now
what an [ __ ] that's like when you're
[ __ ] mad at somebody
and you want to talk [ __ ] about them and
then you send the person you're mad
about a text
anyway the golden knights
the golden knights are playing tonight
i'm going to watch that series
now i'm [ __ ] over it you know it was
just clear
that the um
that the uh the islanders were the
better team this year i mean
just i mean they just dominated [ __ ]
dominated you know we had a nice
little bit of a comeback in game five
but it wasn't enough
um in game five two what the [ __ ] 44
shots the 19 and we lose five to four
so um but i think you know cam neely and
everybody did such a great job with the
bruins team again this year
and uh they always seem to make the
right moves to make us better so
we shall see what happens next season
you know
i don't give a [ __ ] what happens i'm
always gonna watch him that's it it's
called being a fan
okay there you go you bandwagon
[ __ ]
all right anyway plowing ahead here um
okay so that was that was the hey that
was a rough one that was the bad part
of the uh of
of my night last night
by the way let's check in on the
brooklyn nets that little you know
upstart team that won by like 40 points
in their first [ __ ] game it's so
stupid they're up two games to none oh
well let's take a look at the series
let's take a look at the series brook
lynettes
do i even want to look at this what did
they win the second game by 50
game two that's what i need to look up
the game two highlights
game two score
let's see what happened
uh game two 125 to 86
i mean is that the same [ __ ] thing
again
39 that was game two okay what was game
one
game one score
ah 115 107. that was actually a game
there for a second
um anyway why is why
did i shake off the bruins lost because
today is my birthday
and my wife went out got me the coolest
[ __ ] gift
i've ever had you know those cameos
where celebrities wish you a happy
birthday
the the person the best cameos out there
are uh sebastian bach
um one of the great lead singers front
man one
a huge fan of his she got me hit uh
she got me the cameo with him wishing me
happy birthday and i just sat there just
freaking the [ __ ] out i mean i kind of
knew she was gonna do it because i was
saying listen
i don't need anything i got enough
t-shirts and [ __ ] i want
you know i want to see uh
sebastian wish me a happy birthday and
she got it for me and it was just like
why i became a fan of his cameos is
because the guy goes all out they're
like
he'll do like 15 minutes shows you
around his house
or the one he did for me he was at some
kiss museum and he was
showing all the stuff that he had was
hilarious he's like these are the kiss
pillows i got that one i got that one i
need that one
um it was so [ __ ] awesome so thank
you to him thank you to my wife and
everything i
i uh she did take a little video of me i
was she gave me breakfast in bed with
waffles and i watched sebastian bach
wish me a happy birthday uh who for my
money is one of the best front men
of all time i always tell you guys this
watch him sing monkey business on
snl and the guys he's he's acting like
he's at the [ __ ] o2 arena
and you know he's he's in front of like
400 people and the guy is acting like
it's 4 million
it's uh it's what it's all about it's
what it's all about i love that guy
so thank you to him and thank you to my
wife uh for making that happen
it was um it was so
surreal and every time he said my name
you don't understand like i saw
them open for aerosmith at the boston
garden new year's eve december 31st
1989. i just lost my license for
drinking and driving things were not
going for this orange-headed jerk-off
and but i went to that show and um
and i just had like the best i had the
best time and he came out and they were
a new band that was their first album
and they came out and they just [ __ ] it
ripped
and he was funny you know when he was
talking in between the uh
the songs and everything and uh then of
course aerosmith came out the bad boys
of boston
and i remember at the end of the night i
think they all came there was some sort
of like set they had
that aerosmith had i want to say it was
either a subway i think it was a subway
they acted like they all got out of the
subway
you know at the boston garden or
something like that i forget what it was
a long time ago jesus christ almost 32
years ago
and in the end they did the countdown
and they all came out they were having
you know i think aerosmith was sober by
then so they were probably just
having some sort of [ __ ] fruit punch
or some [ __ ] but uh everybody came out
and toasted the crowd it was
awesome and uh if you ever told
you know old freckled billy with no
driver's license
at that point that sebastian
sebastianbach the lead lead singer of uh
skid row was going to wish me a happy
birthday someday i mean that would have
been it
that would have been it for me so thank
you to him and my wife for making it
happen
because it was [ __ ] awesome greatest
birthday gift ever
hands down not even close um
all right so getting back to um
let's see here what did i want to talk
about oh you got to see this new
documentary
this new documentary out on uh showtime
called the kings
and this is about um
my favorite time in boxing
uh when i was growing up everybody talks
about mike tyson in the 80s but mike
tyson in the 80s was total domination
like the [ __ ] islanders the last
three games against my bruins
he was just he just dominated everybody
and um but like if you just wanted to
see
like i don't know just for the greatest
fighters of all time
not only fighting at the same time but
fighting each other
it was i guess that welterweight
middleweight division
so this documentary is about that time
um it's about sugar ray leonard
tommy hitman hearns marvin hagler
and uh hands of stone there um the [ __ ]
am i going blank on his name
there um
dude what the [ __ ] i i swear to god i
gotta i gotta start taking that alpha
brain [ __ ]
i literally just watched three episodes
of it last night and i'm going totally
blank on his name
hands of stone come on bill
roberto duran what an [ __ ] and i you
know they had the whole backstory of him
all the [ __ ] that was going on in panama
and you know what's cool is they they do
like they do like this parallel
of uh what was going on in politics what
was going on in america at the time
and um
you know jimmy carter he who just always
got [ __ ] back then he was like
i feel like the last like humanitarian
that was ever president that really
seemed to like
just care about just humanity in general
beyond caring about american people he
just cared about people and human rights
and that type of stuff
so of course he was destroyed
you know and viewed as weak and all of
this [ __ ]
and uh you know there's a couple of
speeches he gave he gave at one point he
goes you know who you are as a person
used to be about what you did
not what you had and he kind of gave
america this stern talking to
about consumption and how it was an
empty pursuit
that's what he was talking about right
before greed is good came in
and then reagan came in who just was
like
you know i mean he was a [ __ ] movie
star the guy had like
you know i i mean i know there's been
some people that came along that had
some star power since then but this guy
was like a legit movie star
which is why back in the day you know i
think back in way back in the day like
roman times or something or in greece
they would not let actors run for
political office because they were like
well
they're too good at faking [ __ ] we're
not going to know what they're really
thinking right
so they cut to him and he's you know
got that smile and he just you know yeah
that's what it is
but i didn't realize that that guy uh
was the one doing the make it up make
america great again
and the people who put together this
documentary were obviously not
fans of his so they made it look like he
was sort of doing that dog whistle
race-baiting [ __ ]
oh look who's here
happy birthday oh
billy baby
you gotta finish it now happy birthday
to use to use
thank you come on in and you're in the
middle of saying something about race
mating
oh cause you you tapped out on that
documentary and i was saying how
i didn't realize i mean the people who
make the documentary are obviously
not fans of his so ronald reagan
okay and he was the guy that did the
first make america great again
and he was doing that whole you know
getting back to the way it was you know
white people we look back you know the
good old days for us
and not the good old days for you used
guys there so he was doing that now
whether he was just being you know
you know living in his white world when
he said it but they were saying that he
was doing the whole dog whistle thing
for
uh you know let's get this back to where
it was but i will say this though
they did show this part in the
documentary which was a part of america
that
i remember when i was a kid where you
know there was guys who were just like
the milkman
and he could have he could make enough
money to have a stay-at-home wife
and all he did was drive a truck drop
off milk bottles and pick up empty ones
the simplicity of that life and he had
enough money to have a house
and if his wife wanted to work she could
work if she didn't she didn't have to
and everybody was fine and you had food
on the [ __ ] table
and um they were talking about they
showed this
this great bit uh that memory is about
as
white as the milk he delivered every day
nothing why everybody people had that
black people had that too if you know
but
i just wanted to make a milk and white
joke i know it wasn't great i just
wanted
i just wanted to do it oh now who's race
payton
so the old race mate the old race bait
um so anyway listen to me trying to sit
next to me too because my
stupid [ __ ] thing is screwed up i
have two microphones but they're messed
up there's something else for your
birthday right now but it requires me
kind of being on my phone but i'm here
for you baby
hey why did you come out here if you're
not going to be on the podcast
loud and be like happy birthday all
right are you gonna be down next to me
here
are you gonna be here this afternoon i'm
not doing [ __ ] today
all right just making sure i but i got i
do have to leave for the gym
in like 10 minutes so what are you
talking about so they were showing how
to face old face killer
when when detroit
in the 60s was sort of say hello to my
old friend
[Laughter]
trying to think what other funds i could
make today all right i thought you came
out here
to participate i didn't think you came
out here to just trash me did you tell
them about your birthday gift
yes i did it was [ __ ] awesome
what is he saying by the way what do you
mean what does he say
what is the entire skid row i don't know
what they say 18
is like you got it 18
[Music]
no that's poison you [ __ ] they say
um ragdoll daddy little qd that's
aerosmith you jerkface that's awesome
that's def leppard i said job that's van
halen
go
[Music]
what about impressive that you know
impressive you know all these songs
um
[Laughter]
that's the bay city rollers
do they saying wow yeah
is that what their song sounds that
might be joan jett i don't know who that
last one
18 in life nope don't know it youth gone
wild
monkey business my favorite one you
should know it
you should doubt it
well i guess i'm gonna have to take you
out to go see him
well i'm glad you enjoyed that i like
how you keep going what else i just
named the three biggest hits like you're
gonna know some deep cut oh
she's my cherry pass they sang that one
right
no that was warrant not warrant that was
uh
who was that that's when all the w bands
came out it was warrant
white lion uh great white
do they sing heaven isn't
too far away or whatever those words are
yeah i don't forget who that was but
that was a that's when it was ending
that's when it was like ending and then
then skid row came along
and they [ __ ] were crushing it oh
they said girls girls
molly crew oh okay
i really don't know their catalog i've
showed it to you
how many times i showed you that that
clip of of of them on snl when they sang
monkey business and he just [ __ ] just
destroys
hmm well that's great
i'm kind of feeling like my birthday's
over and like we're going back to just
being the jerk
you always are to me it's birthday
anyway
so they were showing how all of you
didn't have to have like a high school
education you could get a job
in um you know one of the big three
uh chrysler ford or uh gm and you could
you could work
build these cars you could afford to
have a car you could have a house
and it was and i just remember just
watching it like why couldn't they just
let us have that
you know just keep letting us have that
and they could still have their [ __ ]
house on the hill and look down on
blue-collar people but why would you
take that away
from the [ __ ] middle class and then
what i love is that
morons blame republicans
and [ __ ] uh democrats which i felt
this documentary was kind of acting you
know going to do
oh these then the republicans came in
it's like it's corporations
that own them you know that's what i
feel i just i think they all work for
the same people but
it went back to that period and they
showed detroit
before the the race riots and everything
and then the white flight and all that
and what an amazing city
that it was and it's just uh it's just a
[ __ ] shame that people don't get
along and then stuff like that happens
and 50 years later they're still dealing
with it that's all nia
that's all i wanted to say okay well all
right
yeah you feel pretty strongly about it
well maybe i need to give it another
chance i did you know something new
people have been saying for a while
where's nia she needs to come back on
the podcast and you're coming out here
i miss you guys and you're coming out
here
it feels great to be back i don't feel
like i'm phoning it in
what are you talking about you're
sitting here birthday i keep
i like don't do that don't do much
because you're being sweet and then i
take a step towards you
and then you talk about my old face and
then i pull away and then you go oh come
here
yeah the old push pull i know don't do
that how do you feel
i feel fine i feel i felt [ __ ] great
uh when i i just the cameo thing that's
all i needed
that's all i needed you got me a couple
of new hats for my [ __ ] old bald head
i didn't get to do that the kids got it
oh the kids got me that oh yeah
my daughter came in was just like happy
birthday dad
she had that cute look and she sang
happy birthday to me
it's over he gave me waffles in bed
that's it
that's it that's it so i'm i'm done and
now i'm not doing [ __ ] for the rest of
the day other than this podcast
good so let me ask you this near because
the fans want to know
okay why do you think the boston bruins
just couldn't figure out
the new york islanders once they once
they evidently figured us
out figured out how to beat us what
happened what would you say
were the top three uh breakdowns
or or or whatever that caused us to just
get so unceremoniously
booted from the playoffs well you know
that's a complex question
but you know what i noticed was that
chara was like really in his head you
know
and so that has a lot to do with it also
probably because he was traded to the
capitals but go ahead well that's the
thing
and that just affected the whole team
morale
exactly exactly bill i mean how do you
think that affected everybody else it's
like
we love the guy now he's playing for
somebody else oh man
we're not gonna be as strong as we used
to be that was pretty good though
that until you started laughing at it
like that wasn't bad like
missing chara i'll go with that so much
all right give me the second one
um the second one it's like did you guys
see
like the rink like the ice like i don't
know
maybe it's just me but it just felt like
it looked a little
like slick like slicker than normal like
a little wet
like i don't know like so did you think
the islanders were a faster team so
maybe they made the ice a little cooler
so they could skate a little faster i
i just feel like there was some weird
[ __ ] going on with that because when i
was looking at it i was like
it looks a little all right i like that
okay little conspiracy theory little we
missed the old guy
okay number three what do you got also i
just felt like the referees
were i don't know like there was one guy
he was looking really like shady to me
like i don't know the guy personally
but like i just he was kind of standing
in the corner he was like like
science going back and forth and he was
like rubbing his hands together
and he was like like he's whispering to
the other right yeah it's not good when
the refs are whispering to one another
i was like what are they talking about
you know well you know what
so i just felt like oh and then then
they also were like whispering to the
coach
of the team that won and it was like
what are they whispering about the
islanders it was like what are you guys
whispering
oh are you on an island of your own like
see what is that about what does that
mean
so i don't know there's a lot of all
right that was nia renee hill
and i didn't like it i didn't like it at
all i like it one bit
so if you had to choose between uh
the vegas knights in the montreal
canadiens who's winning that series
ooh well here's the thing about the
vegas knights
it's a gamble am i right um
all right all right nia thank you thank
you for being on
thank you for being on the podcast
amusing yourself
am i right come on people all right i
have to read advertising here thank you
so much
for the no for the cameo the cameo man
is this bill reading
advertising uh
[ __ ] what does this say all right
here we go
butcher box it's pretty good it's pretty
accurate
all right but uh definitely check out
check out the the kings on on showtime
[Music]
i had no idea i always thought that
sugar ray leonard
fought tommy hearns and lost the first
time and then had to come back and beat
him the same way he lost to duran first
and then had to come back and beat him
i didn't realize that tommy had that
fight won
but uh i always thought that the
weakness of tommy hearns was that
he loved to fight so even if he had a
fight won
he if you started just wanting to just
stand flat-footed and trade
he was all about that and it's because
of that
that when he fought marvin hagler that
that the greatest round in boxing they
say the first round
um um marvin agler versus uh tommy
hearns
and i just i don't know just took me
back to that whole time and you know
what's so funny to watch that
documentary on the heels
of that [ __ ] youtube guy and uh
mayweather
and even really mayweather's last like
six fights and now he's like i guess
somebody said he was bragging about he's
the
best legal bank robber out there
mayweather which is kind of funny as a
comedian
i have to admit it's kind of funny to be
like hey you dumb [ __ ] i stole your
money again we're like we know
um [ __ ] disgusting i know but we
still watching all right shh
please just let me shush you here i
gotta read this here all right mack
weldon everybody
um when that mackie starts [ __ ]
welding
he's gonna kick off your summer with
style
with brands that's reinventing
men's basics mark weldon mark weldon's
full collection includes t-shirts polos
buttons up
shorts and pants i don't say short pants
shorts pants swimwear and so much more
with light and breathable fabric
technology
mac welding keeps you cool and
comfortable all summer
from working to working out happy hour
to playing with your kids
mark mack weldon has men's essentials
for whatever your day includes
dive into mack weldon's swim line with
trunk and board shorts
uh short options that are quick to dry
and have four-way stretch fabric so no
matter which way you're bending
forward backward this way that way you
got your leg up
it's it's stretching with you uh you're
not in the
uh when you're not in the pool mac
weldon's new maverick tech
chino shorts and radius shorts are the
perfect addition to your summer wardrobe
they'll keep you comfortable so you can
confidently power through
your most active days mac weldon also
has a free loyalty program called
weldon blue level one gets you free
shipping for life
once you reach level two by spending 200
you get 20
off every order for the next year stay
cool this summer and looking great doing
it with
doing it with all new collections of
men's essentials from mack weldon
uh for 20 off your first order visit
macweldon.com
w-e-l-d-o-n uh dot com slash burn enter
the promo code burr
that's mac weldon m-a-c-k-w-e-l-d-o-n
dot com slash promo code bird that's for
20 off mac weldon
reinventing men's basics
that's pretty good all right helix
everybody alex
there's nobody on the planet like you
woo so why would you buy a generic
mattress built for everyone else
helix sleep has a question that has a
quiz that just takes two minutes to
complete and matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you
why why would you buy a mattress made
from someone else
with helix alex uh you're getting a
mattress that you know will be perfect
for the way
you sleep everybody's unique
helix knows that so they have several
different mattress models to choose from
they have soft medium and firm
mattresses
mattress is great for cooling you down
if you sleep hot gross
and even a helix mattress for plus size
folks it's been
awesome getting messages from so many of
you
who also found the helix mattress of
your dreams what are you
freaking out about not the copy
all right handle whatever you handle all
right
so if you're looking for a mattress you
take the quiz you order the mattress
that you're matched to and the mattress
comes right to your door's shipped for
free
you don't even need to go to a mattress
store again just go to helixsleep.com
take their two-minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life
they have a 10-year warranty and you try
to and you get to try it out for 100
nights risk-free
they'll even pick it up for you if you
don't love it but you will
uh helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at helixsleep.com
all right we got one more here oh my
bookie how the [ __ ] you doing hey
everybody ufc
263 263 263
however you say it is going down this
weekend and if you're scrambling to
place your bets
problem solved mybookie.a.g has you
covered
better yet use our promo code bird or
grab yourself a deposit bonus
up to 1 000 and take advantage of fights
uh
like the highly anticipated rematch
between israel
adesin naya and marvin
veteri uh let's be honest the only thing
more exciting than watching two beasts
throwing haymakers
is cash in your account when the final
bell rings and if you want
nba and nhl playoff action my bookie has
no
shortage of game lines championship
futures and they've got the best player
props
in the industry sign up use the promo
code mybookie.com
a.g to grab yourself some extra funds on
top of your deposit and stay
and start your day off with the win
that's extra cash in your con
your account you're a [ __ ] that's extra
cash in your account so you get the best
you get you bet the best games and
events all summer long
my bookie.ag promo code burr b-u-r-r
bet anything anytime anywhere
with my bookie jesus i'd like to tell
you that was the worst i've ever done
but
it was pretty average get up near the
mic
i was trying to do something else for
your birthday i'm good sebastian bach
wish me a happy birthday i'm good
you know what listen does anyone out
there have any
connections with the new beverly cinema
because anybody
out there that like
anybody there you got me stinking
old-school metal now quentin tarantino
does anybody
wonder you said the tickets were going
on sale at 9 00 a.m
i was on at 9 a.m refreshing refreshing
oh
and then i just gotta know
in that time frame that i was on the
podcast i missed being able to get look
what i was gonna get
get you oh
[ __ ] it was a double feature
and it's sold out just like that all
right getting
alerts and notifications on my twitter
for when they went on sale i had
everything set
i was sitting here refreshing his uh
bullet in the getaway
double feature at tarantino's movie
theater i'm in here and then by the time
i finish doing my bit on it i i missed
the window is that this the only night
that they have it
it was the sixth those it was three
nights in a row and they're all sold out
well you know something that's good the
movie theaters are sold out again it's
all right
tarantino always has great movies
showing down there we can go somewhere
this was this i saw this like two weeks
ago that they were doing this and i know
this was something you would have loved
to see
well nia you blew it you ruined my
birthday
thanks a lot
oh well i tried did you tell him what
else i got you
you got me a hat
and you got me a blue hat you got me a
gray hat
sebastian bach wish me happy birthday
your mom got me a cool helicopter
t-shirt no but what are we doing later
this year oh we're going to uh
vincent van beebe oh red face himself
immersive experience
i went to his his joint out there in
holland or where was denmark one of
those times i was
going around i liked his stuff when is
my birthday
thing that i have to pick out i know
it's in december
it's a long ways away december long ways
it's sort of a birthday christmas thing
it was all [ __ ] sold out no no
no no no no it's not a birthday
christmas thing you don't get to combine
them my birthday
i do get to combine them my birthday's
in june
christmas is in december then i'll just
sign up for something be like oh i blew
it
i was gonna do it and then i blew it try
to make comedy gold
podcast you stink
okay if i'm gonna get you something i
deliver you did why don't you stand
outside the movie theater we'll see if
we can scalp some tickets
come on i'll give you a [ __ ] what's
that eight bucks what do movie tickets
go for now
they're 12 at the new beverly cinema
wow that's a bargain to see those two
movies i know
it's really a [ __ ] bummer i shouldn't
have done your
silly podcast even though i gave the
people what they wanted which was like
comedy on comedy on comedy i mean
yeah they're just happy just to hear
your voice this hockey bit was i
thought was pretty great off the top of
the dome
ridiculous person all right that's it
everybody
i'll improv right up the dome you should
teach a class
how to come in improv on your husband's
podcast and then
[ __ ] up his birthday that's fantastic
what's your next trick nia you gonna
ruin [ __ ] flag day for me
are you going to ruin father's day for
me
i know you got the whole day
you got the whole day on mother's day
you got the whole damn day
on mother's day what am i going to get a
[ __ ] uh little tie tack and a uh
a beard brush do they make those
all right that's it that is the podcast
everybody that's it for the podcast
everybody thank you so much for joining
us yes but
enjoy the music picked out by andrew
femilis uh
which should be some [ __ ] skid row if
we're doing it right
and then uh there'll be a bonus half
hour uh
footage of a thursday afternoon just
before friday monday morning podcast
from a few years ago whatever that's how
it works that's it happy birthday to me
happy birthday birthday bibi
all right happy birthday to anybody
else's birthday out there and the rest
of you relax your day's coming
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday
june 10th 2013.
happy birthday to me happy birthday to
me
happy birthday you read [ __ ]
happy birthday to me
yeah what's going on oh sorry just
yelled there
i'm excited this is the first time i've
been doing
been doing this podcast for
six years and not once
has the po have the podcasting guards
ever graced me with the podcast that
actually fell
on my birthday and i'm going to go out
on a limb here and i'm going to say
despite the fact
that there are over 7458 podcasts on my
street alone that i am the first
podcaster to ever host a [ __ ] podcast
on his birthday
i'm putting that out there all right
you can go wikipedia google it or do
whatever the [ __ ] you want to do with it
i'm telling you i'm the first one who
ever did it these other guys
and women who said that they did it
they're just talking all right that's
just talk over there i'm actually
[ __ ] doing it
um so i don't know what you're thinking
right now you're like well bill
it's your birthday first question
everybody asked
how old are you now i'm 45.
let me tell you something about the
fives for all you youngsters out there
it's not the ones it's not the twos it's
not the sevens it's the fives
the fives get you you know what i mean
25. you know 24 kind of scares you but
[ __ ] here we go sliding into 30.
you know that's when you're right on top
of the fence there right
the [ __ ] berlin wall you know which
way am i gonna fall
free side or the [ __ ] side
right aging is like
it's like reverse progress so you would
actually when you get to the fives you
fall back over into [ __ ] uh
post world war ii german i guess
from now until for forever it's going to
be post world war ii bill what
you know what the [ __ ] i'm talking about
whenever they put up that goddamn wall
when did they put it up they put it up
during uh kennedy
or was it in 1948 who was that israel
i don't [ __ ] remember um 35 was a
[ __ ]
they all suck i'm not gonna lie to you
they all suck but 35 was a [ __ ]
and now 45. [ __ ] i mean i'm sliding into
50.
does that even make sense i'm still
doing pull-ups
[Laughter]
how can i be 45 when i'm still doing
pull-ups that doesn't make any [ __ ]
sense
because when i was a kid old people
nobody actually nobody worked out when i
was a kid
nobody strap like i've never seen my dad
try to touch his toes
my entire [ __ ] life i never seen him
do a jumping jack
i never saw any of his friends none of
them
they just rolled out of bed you know
sat on the side of the bed for a second
going ah jesus christ
oh my god i'm tired and then they get up
brush your teeth
take a shower put on some clothes have
bacon and eggs and go out to work
you know then they [ __ ] come home
they'd walk through the door and be like
all right all right call it
everybody would shut the [ __ ] up and
then they'd sit down and they eat their
[ __ ] beef stew
and then they go in the living room
they'd sit down in their chairs
[ __ ] tired what what'd you do today
uh yeah billy listen i'm tired okay all
right just just
go to your room go to your room you know
then they'd watch a little bit of tv
right and within two hours their [ __ ]
head was just back
right and that was that day there was no
working out whatsoever
there was maybe like two people who
could do still do pull-ups at 45
when i was a kid and it was like johnny
weissmiller
and uh that guy who did the juicer who
used to dress like arthur fonzarelli
when he worked on cars on happy days
i want two three o'clock um hey do you
know something i tell you this i
actually uh
i can't remember because i did that that
quick podcast in the middle of the week
i did an episode of uh nick kroll's show
and i got to work with ron howard's dad
and he was you know he was in cool hand
luke
and he actually told me stories about
being in the uh
i guess he's in he had a small role and
he's in the last scene
where cool hand luke um for those of you
who haven't seen it yet
a spoiler alert all right
stick your fingers in your ears and go
for the next [ __ ] 10 seconds all
right
because i don't want to hear your [ __ ]
um
and the end of the movie when cool hand
luke gets shot in the church
uh he's part of the cops you know that
are taking them out
and then that what we've got here that
guy says no we'll take him from here
he's in that scene
um absolutely legendary and he said they
shot it up in bakersfield california
so there you go and the guy was
hilarious and he was like 85 years old
improv and still sharp as hell um
it was awesome great great guy so thanks
to uh
kroll show and nick kroll for getting me
on because if he didn't i wouldn't have
that experience
and please watch the crow show cause i
think that dude's a [ __ ] genius there
you go
there's my plug for the look at that on
my birthday hyping somebody else's
project
you know what that isn't right that
isn't right at all it's very generous
why are you being a martyr bill
huh don't cry for me [ __ ] billy
um i'm gonna i'm gonna hype something
right now
hey bill nobody's stopping you it's your
stupid podcast all right
[ __ ] grumpy [ __ ] um
tickets for the billy red state tour
are now on sale uh for a number of the
venues uh
specifically uh my first two dates
one in uh boise idaho and the other one
in bozeman
hope i'm saying that right montana the
last state
in the union that i've never been to um
and here's the deal you know a lot of
east coast comics like myself
we never travel these states unless
we're doing some college gig or some
[ __ ] but we usually don't come through
here
so it would be great if you guys gave me
some wonderful stories to tell all my
[ __ ] hilarious comedian friends
about where to go to play you know hi
montana
you want the sensation the teen idol
sensation joe
[ __ ] derosa to grace big sky country
well then god damn it sell a pair your
wrangler jeans
get off the meth whatever you gotta
[ __ ] do
and come down to my show i'm just
[ __ ] with you guys i'm hoping that
i'm gonna sell tickets out there what it
really is
and i'm nervous that i'm not going to
which is why i'm already trying to guilt
you guys
into the fact that i'm going to spread
rumors that you guys don't like east
coast comics
even though i'm a hollywood sellout out
here um
so anyways that's the deal the billy red
state tour is coming to a
state near you make stops in idaho
montana south dakota obscure places in
colorado
i don't have the dates in front of me
kansas oklahoma
and uh el paso texas is where it wraps
up
and uh we'd love to see you i'm working
on a badass t-shirt that i'm gonna be
selling
um and selling only on the on the red
red state tour
and uh and that's it all right there you
go i'm done plugging the [ __ ]
so let's get on to this movie that i
wanted to see
until i saw the rating and now it's
[ __ ] annoying the [ __ ] out of me
is uh you know it's the summer season
you know there's actually a wonderful
movie coming up called the heat
that uh certain someone might be in if
you watch the uh the trailer
the heat starring sandra bullock and
melissa mccarthy if you guys could hook
me up
and go buy a movie ticket to that one uh
that would be tremendous
and uh you know be something that i
would enjoy
ah [ __ ] is it any wonder why they don't
have me do press for anything
what the [ __ ] brad pitt i'm looking this
up right now
war z what is the name of this [ __ ]
movie
world war z oh there we go now here's a
[ __ ] movie
here's a guy there's a [ __ ] movie
that i wanted to see
brad pitt world war z end of the [ __ ]
world
right there's zombies
this is [ __ ] the world as we know it
will not
exist in i don't know how many days one
of the great [ __ ] lines
the kind of line that makes me want to
get off my [ __ ] couch you know
put on my slippers put on a smoking
jacket and go down to the local movie
theater
and take in a picture right and then at
the end of it after they show everybody
running for their [ __ ] lives
it's the end of the goddamn world
world war z what what what i don't even
know what that is
it was world war one world war two they
said [ __ ] all the numbers right through
infinity
[ __ ] the entire alphabet all the way to
the last letter world war
z i'm i'm [ __ ] i'm there i gotta see
this [ __ ]
and then in the end what do they do to
me rated pg-13
oh go [ __ ] yourself
all right and that's not to go [ __ ]
yourself to brad pitt or the director or
anybody else
that i'm trying not to burn a bridge
with it's
a [ __ ] you to the [ __ ]
i know that that was a rated r movie in
fact i've heard that it was and they
[ __ ] took the knees out of it and
they [ __ ] drag it down
into pg-13 all right
i don't give a [ __ ] who you are if the
world is ending and you're getting
chased by zombies
you're not running around going oh golly
gee oh
heck crimey's oh jiminy cricket
and once every 10 minutes you go oh [ __ ]
you know you don't
it's the end of the world with zombies
from the beginning once they discover
these zombies
to the end of that movie where they
hopefully solve the problem
should be a bunch of people wait eight
eighty-five percent of the people going
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] are we gonna do
[Music]
and then the other 15 should be grabbing
them by the shoulders going for christ
said get a [ __ ] hold of yourself
right that should be most of the
dialogue in that movie
but now now i don't know i just said it
that way
now it's it's pg-13 so what are they
going to do
well what's going to happen are they
going to slowly you know
have some metaphor for you why we should
not stop using
[ __ ] plastic water bottles so they're
going to weave that into the storyline
you know you know it's funny i actually
tweeted i have to admit that
i hang my head in shame but i did tweet
and i do still consider myself a man
even saying that out loud say it again
bill i tweeted
um i said zombie movies are rated r
hashtag world war z right and most
people agreed so of course this one [ __ ]
goes
i have to respectfully disagree said the
success
of uh the walking dead
that's what he said said the success of
the walking dead
[ __ ] twitter hack it's just like oh
that that's a great idea
i see that business model so let me get
this straight i'm going to spend over
[ __ ] 150 million dollars of my money
making a zombie movie and i'm gonna make
it no more [ __ ] crazier
than what people can sit at home on
their couch and watch that's what the
[ __ ] you're telling me that's that right
there
that's your business model that makes
sense to you
forget about all the [ __ ] who are gonna
steal the movie anyways
or just man i'll just wait a few weeks
and then i'll watch it on [ __ ]
whatever right
you want to get them out you want to get
them excited see
they come down and go see the picture in
a big screen
get themselves some popcorn sitting
there with their best gal right
you're going to make it you know what
why don't you just make according to
jim's world war z
you know no disrespect
to jim or according right
i'm just saying what what the [ __ ] what
is the purpose
it's like when you go out to your
favorite pizza place if you could make
the pizza just as good at home
you wouldn't [ __ ] go out there or if
someone would just show up to your
[ __ ] house and step out of your tv
and go here's your [ __ ] pizza
you're not going
why the [ __ ] would you make a pg-13
zombie [ __ ] movie could somebody for
the love of [ __ ] god explain that to
me
they've been doing that lately right
super hero movies should also be rated r
unless you're doing one of those douchey
ones that nobody cares about
all right but all the other ones batman
captain america all that [ __ ] should all
be rated r
those superheroes are not for kids those
are for adults
who don't know how to fight and want to
live through
somebody else who actually has a
six-pack that's what those movies are
for
i feel you know
and i actually think that i i would take
i would actually go if i ever made a
[ __ ] superhero movie i would go for
the nc-17
you know you remember in spider-man when
he's hanging upside down
and the [ __ ] girls kissing him right
that wouldn't be
he would have been hanging a little bit
lower if you know what i mean he'd still
be upside down but he would be hanging a
little bit lower
come on people do the math
somewhere between 68 and 70 is what i'm
talking about all right
that's how that [ __ ] scene would have
gone down okay and [ __ ] all these
critics
who would be like oh my god that's
absolutely horrific
stan lynch must be [ __ ] rolling over
on his futon
because they never gave him the money
deserved for creating the character
and i i would be i stand by it
i stand by it this is the peter parker
that everyone knew existed but no one
wanted to see
you know he'd be hanging upside down
just washing his [ __ ] spider dick
right in her mouth
okay you know why because he's
because he's spiderman all right
half man half spider
using the power for good and he still
has a day job
still has a [ __ ] day job isn't that
great
let me tell what a common man
he's not like bruce wayne walking around
at all these [ __ ] eyes wide shut
parties
you know how many tuxedos does bruce
wayne own
and how did he make his money you know i
know all these comic book people of
losing their [ __ ] minds because i
don't know anything about the backstory
about any of these [ __ ] people and i
don't give a [ __ ]
all right how much what did he do how
did he inherit money when both his
parents got shot in the alley
they're there your parents got killed is
that what the money is spending
he's never working he's never
at work in any of those [ __ ] movies
it's always going over the mayor's house
he's a [ __ ] trust fund kid
peter parker still works for the school
paper or whatever
i'm working for [ __ ] jameson a guy
named after whiskey
all right that [ __ ] guy and i liked when
he wore the black suit too i think that
that one looked better
you know and the suit started
controlling him
i didn't like that that made peter look
weak
all right you know you know i'm in over
my [ __ ] head when i'm talking about
goddamn superheroes here um all right
what are we doing here
17 minutes in and it's time it's time to
talk to you
about how you can shave better hey
everybody i
like doing the shaved ones this makes me
feel like the old days like when you
used to watch baseball and everything
was about
your [ __ ] balls or cologne right
or boozing aqua velva
old spice put it on your nuts right all
right dollar shave club everybody
get a good shave getting a good shave
can be a real pain in the age
searching around through 50 different
brands matching new blades to old
handles
[ __ ] features where your razor
doubles as a flashlight vibrator
toothpick
20 bucks for a new razor it's a complete
ripoff
i talked to you guys about this they
have the stupid blades
locked behind glass right like they're
bars of gold
you know why are people stealing them
because they're a friggin ripoff all
right
friggin you can tell them reading
advertising they're even cursing in this
in the copy here so the hell with it
it's a [ __ ] ripoff
20 bucks for a new razer the hell with
that go to dollarshave.com to get high
quality razors delivered to your door
for just a couple of bucks a month
they've made it so simple to get high
quality 100
guaranteed [ __ ] razors sent on
schedule so you never have to think
about it ever again
every month you get a new pack every
week you change your blade
all right and it's it costs a fraction
of what you pay at retail
all right i want you i want you to try
it go to dollarshaveclub.com
forward slash burr you'll get a free
sample of dr
cabbage easy shave butter
which is awesome with uh your first
shipment
also makes the perfect uh father's day
gift the dollar shave club
something he can actually use all right
would you like to watch tv a little bit
better everybody would you like to watch
it more efficiently
well i got something for you he says
pointing at you with his freckled index
finger
hulu plus hulu plus um you've tried
streaming hit shows on your pc
on hula.com now it's time to start your
free trial of exclusive content in your
living room and on your mobile devices
on hulu plus
this is why i love this thing you can
actually watch it on your your
your smartphone wherever the hell you go
on your tablet i believe is what they
say hey bill why don't you just read the
copy
okay with hulu plus you get total
control to watch thousands of shows
wherever you wherever you want whenever
you want use hulu plus on connected
tvs game consoles blu-ray players roku
apple tv pc or watch from anywhere on
your smartphone or tablet on demand at
all times
and with hulu plus you can binge on full
seasons what's your favorite current
shows
and even full series runs of classic tv
shows it's endless
they got community modern family south
park snl monday night raw the man show
jimmy kimmel family guy and more
hulu plus is only 7.99 a month
look at this you get blades delivered
right to your house
you got tv wherever you want it's
unbelievable
but right now they're offering an
extended free trial of hulu plus that is
only available to the podcast listeners
take control of your tv watching
experience go to the podcast page at
billberg.com and click on the hulu plus
banner
for your extended free trial or go to
huluplus.com
bill again the hulu plus banner on the
podcast page at billbird.com or go to
huluplus.com
bill this right here hulu plus this is
the future this is the way you're gonna
watch tv
you're only gonna watch what you wanna
watch and you're gonna watch it when you
wanna watch
alrighty there you go okay back to the
podcast here
um where the [ __ ] the [ __ ] podcast
you [ __ ]
um oh here's a question somebody had hey
bilbo
faggins now people let's try to keep the
homophobia down a little bit
um he says i went to see your show in
denmark a couple of years ago
or a year i don't [ __ ] remember are
you going to do some more shows in
europe preferably in scandinavia thanks
uh why yes yes i am i'm going to be
coming over to europe
in the beginning of december i'm going
to go all howard dean here we're going
to start in ireland
we're going to go over to england no
we're going to uh i'm going to start in
ireland
i haven't looked at the dates yet but i
imagine i'm going to go to all the
places that i've been to before
and maybe add another couple of cities
but i'm go i'm hoping to go
ireland scotland england denmark
norway sweden and finland again
and uh who knows maybe i can add
something else
maybe in uh where the hell else could i
go
i know if you get too far south in
europe they start to like more they
they're still on that benny hill [ __ ]
where they want us today
they want to see that [ __ ] they're very
into like slapstick
and pratfalls i don't know if that's
true i'm not trying to insult anybody in
france
you know italy or whatever i heard you
can get
halfway through germany
you know oh amsterdam or rotterdam or
some of those places that i've been to
or some other places maybe i could do
some stand-up but i'd love to do it and
i'm trying to keep up on what's going on
over there
over in europe huh what's going on over
in europe everybody
it's time for a new segment called
what's going on in europe
delivered by an ignorant american well
evidently there's floods in germany
on this river that goes all the way down
to the czech republic and they're
they're
moving people out and uh that story made
me sick to my stomach
just having water damage in my house i
can't imagine an entire [ __ ] river
coming through my house so my
condolences to everybody out there
uh vladimir putin is getting divorced
from his [ __ ] wife
you know she doesn't like to be in the
spotlight you know
he likes going out there and lifting up
little boys shirts and blowing bubbles
on their stomachs in front of the press
they're just tuned if they've grown
apart the kids are grown up
they go in their separate ways i think
um
i think vladimir wants a nice hot piece
of ass
you know like in 2008 they speculated
that he was banging some chick
um or was going to marry some chick and
uh
and as far as i could tell with my
ignorance they put that paper out of
business
and i have to tell you as [ __ ] up as
this country's becoming it's still
way better you know because you don't
have to deal with stuff like that
although i am a little disturbed with
obama going to china to be like well hey
how do you
censor your your [ __ ] how do you
censor your people that you're supposed
to be doing the right thing for
you know don't know see and there you go
and that's what's going on in the world
i know what's going on we're turkey
they're having those protests over there
it all started off with a bunch of
hippies because they were cutting down
the
uh the the trees in the park and wanted
to put up a strip mall and all the
hippies in turkey were like
hey man that's not cool man it started
with that [ __ ] and all of a sudden
everybody just snapped
and was like by the way you know [ __ ]
the police and all this other [ __ ]
i like keeping up on that stuff lately i
mean going to that al jazeera
england english whatever which i was
saying on the wednesday the special one
that i thought that the al jazeera and i
know a lot of people listen that right
now like what are you a [ __ ]
terrorist
that's what i thought because lately
i've noticed al jazeera has been on like
your tv
my tv's in like hotel rooms and i'm like
what the [ __ ] do they got this terrorist
channel on here for
um and for those you oversee listening
to this and laughing you have to
understand that the only thing that
we've seen
um unless you seek it out over here is
when they would broadcast americans
getting their heads sawed off
by uh you know al-qaeda that's the only
thing we saw
and the way they would frame it would be
like and they actually televised this
other news channel so i just assumed
that like
that was like you know like ted turner
has tnt and tbs
i thought osama bin laden with that oil
money you know
that was his tnt like al jazeera
[Laughter]
but i've actually found it really
[ __ ] interesting and it's great to
see
uh i don't know that's great just read
about other countries it's not it's not
not you know it's not what you think it
is
and i'm not saying that they don't trust
the us but it's kind of
interesting to read the criticism to
hear their perception of what's going on
here i'm not saying that they're 100
right not saying they're 100 raw oh bill
we get it
you try to broaden your horizons so i've
been checking out that and somebody told
me also check out bbc
world and uh whatever i know they're all
full of [ __ ] to some extent they all
have their angle
but it's uh you know yeah you get enough
angles of [ __ ] maybe you could stand in
the middle of that [ __ ] storm and try to
make sense of it
i don't [ __ ] know um plus i'm hedging
my bets
you know for when the dollar collapses
over here
hopefully at that point i ca i can maybe
uh
then do a billy red state tour over in
[ __ ]
i don't know india i don't [ __ ] know
speaking of which this is another great
reason to go to al jazeera
because he because for those of you
americans who just think it's a
terrorist thing they got some great
stories here
from around the world that you're not
going to hear about here's one for you
referees sentenced
for sex bribe in singapore
a lebanese lineman pled guilty to
accepting sexual
favors in exchange for agreeing to fix a
football match
why wouldn't you just get a hooker you
know
why wouldn't you just gets just go look
at some online porn
good lord go to a bar say hello to
somebody
how [ __ ] late i mean i i don't
understand it i want to see what these
guys look like but here's the story
three lebanese football players have pla
football referees sorry have
pled guilty to accepting free sex
charges from a gambling linked global
syndicate
in return for agreeing to rig a match
with a singapore judge jailing two and
deferring sentencing
sentencing for a third the third guy
just got a hand job
or maybe he was the creep who just liked
to watch um a district court judge on
monday
jailed assistant referee i'm not saying
they're [ __ ] names
uh talk about the first name ali
abdullah he gave him three months
and then the third referee ali another
ali
ali i think over there is that's like
somebody named mike
at least back in the day before they
started naming kids dakota
um the assistant referees broke down
into sobs
when the judge lao lo wee ping
low paying [ __ ] said uh they
could be freed
by later on monday or tuesday after
remission for good behavior and
due to time already served awaiting
their sentences they [ __ ] broke down
and cry
cried all right let me tell you
something i don't know much i don't know
much about going to prison but i know
you don't want to [ __ ] cry
going into prison i don't think you want
to do that
i really don't unless maybe they're
crying because maybe they just
they're putting him into the regular
jail with all the [ __ ] rapists and
that type of [ __ ]
and they got to somehow not get [ __ ]
in the ass
until monday or tuesday jesus christ can
you imagine the calories you would burn
just by stressing that someone was gonna
[ __ ] rape you
in the goddamn booty hole you know what
i mean
i would just think the quivering alone
would be like walking on a treadmill at
like you know
3.1.
um
i don't want to get into that actually
that was a rape joke right is that
[ __ ]
failed comic turned blogger gonna give
me [ __ ] about it
you know i did comedy for a minute and
wasn't successful and these are the
jokes that i think people should be
doing
did you guys see that thing where jim
norton uh was on with that that blogger
person that was just [ __ ] was
hilarious
she was saying that comedy clubs were
filled were basements filled with angry
men and she was coming off
as quite angry herself the whole thing
was [ __ ] hilarious
um and this is the thing about people
who get offended by comedy i want to see
somebody get outside
of their own box you know
i want to see the fat person in the
crowd
get offended by i don't know
i don't know what pick us what a topic a
different topic i'm trying to think
okay a fat guy get offended by
misogynistic
uh material have the dog lover the peta
person
get offended by [ __ ] uh uh
i don't know the rape jokes or whatever
whatever the [ __ ] oh gives a [ __ ]
you know what i mean who goes to a
comedy club and takes jokes seriously
especially as a stand-up comedian
you know what i mean i i just for the
life of me
i'll never [ __ ] understand that
i i don't know i had the right when i
came up
to [ __ ] talk about whatever i wanted
to talk about and i failed miserably
and i flailed and i made big mistakes
and i offended people in the crowd and
all of that [ __ ] [ __ ]
but that was all part of learning to
become a comic
finding what it is you're supposed to be
doing on stage it's part of the learning
process so to try and [ __ ]
just cut that off i don't know i think
it was really just
uh a publicity stunt
you know when you write open letter to
white male comics right there you how
how much harder
could you be trying to be like a
lightning rod
um i don't i don't [ __ ] get that
hey i played guitar for like six seven
years and i'm offended by the chords
eric clapton is using
[Laughter]
and if you're listening to this you
angry blogger i'm just [ __ ] around
it's just
jokes before you get your [ __ ]
panties in a goddamn bunch again but
maybe that's what you should do and then
you can get on another talk show and
discuss
comedy um anyways
plowing ahead by the way i thought jim
was great on it
i thought he was [ __ ] i thought he
was tremendous all right
there we go what else am i talking about
here
um you know i sold lemonade you know
street side
for like three weeks when i was a kid
and um i would like to talk to the
people at lipton iced tea about some of
the things that they're doing with their
iced tea
and lemonade you know
i don't like the arnold palmer i feel
that they should be separate
all right i'm sorry what am i talking
about here let's get back to the podcast
all right can we do that bill for the
love of [ __ ] god oh my apologies to
the chicago blackhawks
by the way my apologies to the chicago
blackhawks
i thought the ellie kings were gonna
beat you guys i really did
and god damn it i'm not don't even act
like you didn't age
during both of those games since the
last time i said that and i got to tell
you a lot of blackhawk fans
really confident talking a lot of [ __ ]
on my twitter
it's almost as if the bruins didn't just
sweep
the [ __ ] uh pittsburgh penguins
i guess that doesn't mean anything to
them i'm impressed with the way that
they beat the la kings evidently
they're not too impressed with sweeping
the pittsburgh penguins and by the way
did anybody watch
uh the um after the bruins one
did anybody watch uh the sydney crosby
press conference that dude would not
give it up to the bruins
on any [ __ ] level whatsoever they'd
be like you know you were held scoreless
you had zero points through four games
in a playoff game
that's never happened to you ever in the
history of your being the wayne gretzky
of right now
why do you think that was he's just like
i don't know you know uh
i don't know it was weird it was like
you know i don't i don't know
do you think it was the goaltending on
the other team he's like nah
that wasn't it yeah i don't think so
when the uh
goaltending we had our opportunities and
uh
just wouldn't go in what do you think
because maybe they they blocked the
shots and they they were
playing good not that wasn't that wasn't
that either
then what was it sydney i actually
respected it on some level that he was
such a competitor
that he was still competing with the
bruins even though the series was over
he just would not give them credit on
any [ __ ] level
for completely disrupting his game four
straight games in a row
you know i mean i'm
look i was as dumbfounded as anybody
that we swept them but i mean
i didn't have any questions at the end
the answers to all of those questions
were sitting on the other bench
and uh and he didn't give it up he
didn't give it up but you know what
dude by the way how many teeth did that
guy [ __ ] lose man
holy [ __ ] that guy is like what is that
it was 1 to 16 up top 17
to 32 on the bottom halfway between
17 and 32 will say that's like numbers
he lost like teeth number 25 26 27
in at least 28 if not 29. he's lost
either four or five [ __ ] teeth
right down the bottom man jesus christ
did you guys ever see that like you want
to talk how tough hockey players are and
i include sydney crosby that as much as
i call him the
pouty lips cub scout that [ __ ] dude
took a slap
somebody i forget i can't remember who
the puck deflected off somebody's stick
and caught him right in the
[ __ ] face broke his jaw and knocked
out it looks
anywhere from three to five teeth they
literally
flew out of his mouth and the [ __ ]
dude gets up and skates off the ice
with the trainers and uh you know i
guarantee you
within five days he was skating again
i don't know i could never do that so
anyways so here we are
the original six the original six are in
the stanley cup we got an original six
for the first time since 1979 when the
montreal canadiens
were playing uh the uh
the new york rangers um
so i'm really excited about that this is
great for hockey and i think it's going
to be a great series and
uh you know i actually watched those
last two games
and uh i want to if brian
bilick and lu and milan lucich
are out on the ice at the same time
that's gonna be [ __ ] unbelievable
because
those are two of the biggest dudes in
the league and uh
it's i think it's gonna be a [ __ ]
awesome series and i hope it doesn't go
six i want this thing to go seven
i hope it's gonna be a classic like i
said the nhl is going to be on the cover
and the nhl playoffs are on the cover of
sports illustrated under the headline
the best
and it's just a great time for hockey
and if they had there's a great
you know stanley cup final you know
maybe they'll get a little more respect
and uh and obviously of course i want my
bruins to win and i'm thinking about
going to a game
i might go in chicago you know i already
went to a playoff game when i was back
in boston
and plus i love those chicago jerseys
the red ones i think
those are one of my favorite ones in the
league and i want to go there and
uh and i won't be a [ __ ] i'm not going
to show up with my brewing [ __ ] i'm just
going to sit there historically
and uh when the bruins score and
hopefully win the [ __ ] game you know
i won't do anything to get the [ __ ]
kicked out of me and i'll go back to my
rented [ __ ]
chevy malibu and i'll drive back to
[ __ ] o'hare and that'll be it
and i'll have that experience speaking
of experiences
it is my birthday everybody and i want
to thank everyone who wish me a happy
birthday
and uh
what was i going to say yeah people are
uh you know
my friends and family in life were
asking me uh you know what i wanted for
my birthday and i told all of them
nothing
look at me don't buy me anything just
like jimmy
and uh and goodfellas all right
i've learned something through the water
damage that i had in my house when i
took everything out of my [ __ ]
closets
in these couple of rooms i have so much
[ __ ] [ __ ]
that i have not used or even looked at
in in years and uh i already gave away
my friend tarkington jersey
i know some people were asking whether
it was still available i gave that away
and i gave it away to the first guy i
read like
i read like 20 emails before i got to
this guy and he actually brought up like
alan page jim marshall carl eller paul
krauss
chuck foreman fred cox right
back when men were named after dicks you
know
and um he knew all that [ __ ]
so i said [ __ ] it i'll give it to give
it to that person
um and if the person who has it is
listening
please take a picture yourself in the
jersey send it to me i'll put it up on
the podcast page if you want if you want
a little uh
little [ __ ] shout out or and actually
will stop people from
suggesting that i would say that there's
a giveaway when there is no giveaway
so anyways um yeah i don't want any more
[ __ ]
i'm not buying any more sports t-shirts
because i get sentimental value
and i can't [ __ ] throw them out and
uh from here on out i'm just buying
those malcolm young
solid color [ __ ] t-shirts and when
they wear out i throw them out
because they don't mean [ __ ] to me and
uh
no i got to do it man i i gotta [ __ ]
get rid of all my goddamn [ __ ] so today
what i'm doing for my birthday
is i think i'm gonna go to the gun range
and i'm gonna go drive out into the
desert
one or the other um
or the other i don't know if i'm gonna
go over the guy i usually go over the
gun range where somebody knows what the
[ __ ] they're doing
i don't like going over there by myself
and just renting a gun
but i gotta tell you it's oddly [ __ ]
relaxing who's kitten who i'm 45 [ __ ]
years old what i'm not gonna do [ __ ] for
my birthday
all right i'm doing my goddamn podcast
and i might go drive out to the desert
because i just want i always wanted to
do that
because i'm a nerd all right that's it
okay so here we go here's the uh
here's some questions for this week um
oh casino carpets
this says part three the final answer oh
this is like a trilogy
like one of those spaces you know what
now i feel bad that i [ __ ] came down
on that girl who's [ __ ] blogging in
the [ __ ]
calling our failed comic like i [ __ ]
know you know what it is if she's still
[ __ ] listening if somebody gives her
this part of it you know what it really
is
is i just can't believe a fellow comic
would [ __ ] attack
i i just can criticize it
with with that angle you know what i
mean
to shrink it down and make it smaller
i just it just blows my [ __ ] mind i'm
just disappointed
disappointed i guess is more the word
the [ __ ] i said before i said out of
[ __ ] anger i didn't mean that [ __ ]
but it's just
[ __ ] you know what i mean
i've been doing this [ __ ] 21 years and
i'm still learning stuff i don't know
[ __ ] about the art right there's no
[ __ ] way i would go
on television and start
you know criticizing other [ __ ] karma
and not to mention like
this whole [ __ ] thing like there's
all these rape jokes being told
is just so [ __ ] inaccurate
like you just walk into a comedy club
and everybody's rape rape rape like
i'm trying to think the only person i
can actually think of
the only rape joke that i that really
stands out that i remember was
jim norton he did a he did a hilarious
one he was talking about uh
going to prison and somebody said jim
would you uh
you think he'd get raped if you went to
prison he goes he goes look at me i
would get raped on the bus ride on in
the way into prison or something like
that i butchered the joke
and it was funny so i i don't know
i i just think you know the last thing
stand-up needs
is for fellow comics to be [ __ ]
trying to mold it into what the [ __ ]
they as an individual think it should be
that just that's just beyond me
why did i get into this [ __ ] i don't
[ __ ] know
you know why because it bugs me all
right here we go casino carpets part
three the final answer
billiam wallace i installed carpet for
six years that guy was only half right
all right that was the guy
last week who claimed that the carpeting
is actually really expensive and it's a
really
high quality and uh so i guess it's
easier to clean or i can't even what the
[ __ ] he said jesus christ
he said yes the casino carpets are a
commercial grade carpet
yes they last a long time
but they aren't crazy colors and designs
because it makes the carpets last
longer the colors and design are a to
hide stains
when you spill a big strawberry
margarita on a solid blue carpet
this the stain will be plain as day
with wacky designs and colors you can't
spot a spilled drink
oh cool b it hides the seams of the
carpet
comes in 12 or 15 foot wide rolls
commercial carpets are usually 15.
that means for every 15 feet in width
you will have a full seam
it was a solid color you would see a
straight line in the carpet for the
entire length of the room
the colors and design breaks up to seem
like camouflage
well there you go love the podcast come
to tulsa sometime and go [ __ ] yourself
oh thank you
um i am coming to tulsa on the billy red
state tour
all right ex-defense minister from
canada speaks out about
speaks uh speaks about
see this is once again not my fault this
person writes ex-defense
minister from canada speaks about out
about
aliens out about aliens
or speaks out about aliens or does he
speak about out about aliens
see what i'm saying this isn't always me
all right bill love the podcast free
lasts
every week uh they're much appreciated
yadda yadda i thought you might like
this link
as you're a big conspiracy theory a big
conspiracy
theorist you mean he said it's the
former canadian defense administrator
no canadian defense minister giving some
bold claims about several species of
aliens living among us and actually
working with elements in the government
uh not only that but a shadowy
cabal c-a-b-a-l-k but cabal i don't know
comprised of the council
on foreign relations the bilderbergers
the
trilateral commission that should add a
hyphen in it you [ __ ]
the international banking cartel
uh the oil cartels members of various
intelligence organizations the select
members of military
one world government check it out sir
the last thing i'm going to do is look
at this i'll put the link up there ah
[ __ ] it i'll look at it right now
this [ __ ] just freaks me out and makes
me depressed because there's nothing i
can do about it
okay now how is this going to help me
sir if i find out there's actually
aliens
living among us talking to international
bankers
you know am i going to come walking in
bursting into their meeting
like the end of a feel-good movie
you know like hey man the people have
spoken
and they like me all right here we go
i i got it right here uh canada's former
minister of national defense
paul hayler testifies at the citizens
hearing
on disclosure where the [ __ ] am i
last month in washington dc that aliens
are living among us
and that it is likely at least two of
them are working with the u.s government
now this guy sounds like he's out of his
[ __ ] mind
okay let's let's let's let's kind of
flip the script here let's say
you're an alien all right whoever's
listening this
still who believes in aliens who isn't
blogging about my reaction to the
blogger
um and you go to you go to another
[ __ ] solar system another galaxy
whatever the [ __ ] terminology is
and you land there okay
what are you gonna do other than try and
get blended
blend in so people don't chop your
[ __ ] alien head off
like how exactly did this [ __ ] alien
get infiltrate the government
this is like mr smith goes to washington
the alien just lands and just goes okay
uh right i mean how come he didn't do
this in argentina
he picks the united states goes right
into [ __ ] washington dc
walks into the capitol building as
somebody's filibustering so they can't
make an electric car or whatever comes
right out on the house floor
and then does what you know
security comes up tries to shoot him and
he just puts his hands up and their guns
turn into like chocolate bars or fall to
the ground
and then for some reason everybody in
their suits doesn't scramble
and freak the [ __ ] out you know
no if you just [ __ ] walk out there
say hey let's go now relax relax
relax it's a simple technology that you
guys will discover if you become friends
with me
how to turn a [ __ ] gun into some
melted [ __ ] that uh
doesn't let people shoot you i am from
the planet zoltar
right he always begins with a z
how does that work like if you were a
[ __ ] alien
and you went to another goddamn planet
exactly
i guess okay you'd be like all right if
there's a bunch of different nations
which one seems to be running [ __ ] i
gotta chop the head off
and you're just gonna want you when you
want a buddy
two of you gonna walk in [ __ ] arm and
arm
and do what yeah hey listen uh i think
just the simple fact that we were able
to get here
you know the kind of firepower that
we're capable of
um for some [ __ ] reason we want to
take over this planet
or we want you guys to do [ __ ] the way
we feel
that it should be done
who would want that [ __ ] headache
i i don't know that i believe this [ __ ]
anyways
he believes what helya whose beliefs on
extra life
extraterrestrial life in uso ufos are
well established
made the statements at the
non-governmental hearings chaired by six
former u.s
congressmen and aimed at according to
the event's website
doing what the u.s congress had failed
to do
for 45 years seek out the facts
surrounding the most important issue of
this or any other time
evidence pouring towards an
extraterrestrial presence engaging
the human race all right you know what
even i have my limits when it comes to
that type of [ __ ]
all right i don't think that's the most
pressing thing i would say us [ __ ] up
the environment world population
and that type of [ __ ] is a little more
unless you want to throw more people
from other galaxies also living here
do they drink bottled water too
[Laughter]
all right here we go people e-voice all
right e-voice is the reason why you're
going to make more money in 2013. when
your customers call you'll have your own
toll-free number
professional greeting dial by number
name directory and more
you'll sound like a fortune 5 company
even though you're still in your cubicle
and blow away your competitors e-voice
lets you give out one number
that rings wherever you are the beach
the bar doesn't matter you sound like
you're at the office
you gotta go to evoice.com and use the
promo code bill
evoice even takes all your voicemails
transcribes them and sends them to you
instantly
as a text or an email so you can check
voicemails before the meeting ends
and not look rude e-voice is only 10
bucks a month
right now listening to my podcast you
can get a free trial of e-voice for 30
days
stop what you're doing hit pause stop
listening to this podcast right now
set up your e-voice and free trial and
uh see what i'm talking about it's a
great way to support my podcast and an
easy way to make more money this year go
to evoice.com promo code bill
that's evoice.com promo code bill or
just go to the podcast page on
billboard.com and click on the e-voice
banner right now
okay demand great system everybody this
father's day think the man great what is
the man great u.s they are 100 percent
made in america cast iron grilling
grates that are revolutionizing the way
people grill
heavy-duty grilling grates deliver
exactly what you need to achieve that
perfect steakhouse flavor
chicken steak or veggies will never have
tasted so good no more flare-ups no more
dry meat
guaranteed named one of 2012's best
grilling accessories by men's health
magazine
man grates are the the perfect gift for
dad this father's day
how do you get them well you go to man
great.com and enter the coupon code bur
b-u-r-r
for their 1999 father's day special or
click the man great banner on the on
the show website sorry 100 made in
america cast iron 100
steakhouse quality grilling in your
backyard remember each monday morning
podcast order comes with a heavy duty
grilling brush
again that's the man great grill
enhancement system order today man great
dot com
man greatruck.com and enter the coupon
code burr at the checkout
and last but certainly not least
legalzoom
america was built by innovators and
dreamers people like nicola
tesla preston tucker and thomas crapper
but it's the inventors and entrepreneurs
all around us people like you that make
america such a great country
this month legalzoom.com celebrates and
innovators
inventions and people who want to get
out of their jobs by helping you launch
your own dream
apply for a patent to secure your
invention
hang in there bill you can do it uh
register your trademark to protect your
product
and services incorporate or form an llc
and launch your business stream
just call or visit legalzoom.com and
they'll take care of you from start to
finish
they've already helped about a million
businesses get started right
celebrate innovations with legalzoom and
for a limited time get a special price
on trademark
copyright and patent applications by
using the referral code bur burr
at checkout protect your creations and
launch your dream at
legalzoom.com legalzoom can provide
self-help services at your specific
direction
or they can connect you to an attorney
uh
but they're not a law firm don't forget
to use that referral code burr b-u-r-r
all right there you go
here we are winding down the final
minutes
of the podcast let me close this right
here
i don't want to save that
ah [ __ ] this happens every goddamn week
older all right here we go
next letter this letter is about an
older lady
um i'm a 29 year old guy and for the
last two years i've been seeing an
incredible
incredibly amazing woman that is 13
years older than me
and you know what it's not going to work
out sir
because you're 29 and she's [ __ ] 42.
you know that doesn't seem to work out
women can do that
for some reason they can do it you know
didn't you learn anything with ashton
kutcher it ain't gonna happen
you know when you're 37 she's going to
be 50.
come on 37 you can still pull a 27 year
old
you're coming home to her right she's
starting to get hot flashes she's taking
geritol i mean
it's not going to work i'm sorry let me
continue she's sexy
fun and we share a lot of common
interest we talked about what direction
our relationship was going to take
very early on and we decided that
keeping it casual was the way to go
smart move smart move now what is taking
a casual meet
that means i [ __ ] you once every six
weeks in my birthday
my birthday in my my why'd i say
birthday
in my book you know what it is it's my
birthday and i want to get on with it i
want to go drive out to the desert
that's what it was
uh we didn't commit to each other in any
official sense
but neither of us saw anyone else
well jesus christ now you're going to
catch feelings for over the two years i
fell in love with her there you go and
wanted to commit so we
could make a real go of it i [ __ ] up
though i never confessed
those feelings to her i was afraid of
things eventually hitting a wall because
of the age difference so i felt safer
not telling her
she recently told me she has wanted the
same things i do this whole time
but she has now met someone closer to
her own age
promising the real relationship i never
gave her i believe she has feelings for
me
but thinks this is the best choice for
her what do i do do i stand up and fight
for what i want
consequences be damned or should i let
her go and accept that age difference is
an
insurmountable problem on a side note
i've been in many relationships i know
myself well enough to know the
difference between love and infatuation
well then if you know the difference i
would go for what you want
okay as an outsider i would say let her
go
um and even though you know the
difference between love and infatuation
do you want to have a family sir
you know because if you do you need to
marry this girl in a week and start
pumping out the [ __ ] kids because
she's already 42.
are you ready to do that because if
you're not you got to let her go
all right that's all i got to say
i'm sorry that's all i got on that one
all right wife not down with the with
the
with nose job wife not down with nose
job
all right dear billy boy love the
podcast love to stand up thanks for that
well you're welcome thank you for
uh thank you for typing that um because
i'm a 31 year old guy i'm happily
married
to a usually supportive wife
i've never been too much of a
self-conscious person but ever since i
was a teenager
if there was one thing i could change
about my physical appearance it would be
my nose
it's a little big and has a bump on the
ridge
uh now okay he said reference the
profile on nikolai
tesla or the ruler constantine to get
the idea
obviously a giant nose with the with
severe acne was immediate fuel for
insult
through junior high school for the
hordes of 14 year olds i
vowed that one day oh
i'm sorry i i'm just a [ __ ] worse
here i vowed that one day i would get a
nose job to boost my self-esteem
well i am now in a position where i can
pay to have the surgery
um i used to ask my wife a few years
back what she thought about and she said
that if it makes me happy then do it
however now that i am closer to having
one
having it done she seems to have changed
her mind she says that she could she
couldn't get used to seeing me look
different
and isn't sure if she'll like the uh the
way the remodeled me looks
i'm disappointed because i really want
to have it done
and wish she would be supportive the
thing is my wife is a self-conscious
person
and i'm worried that on a small level
she thinks that the new me will be more
attractive
and warrant the attention of more
females
this is not what i'm this is not why i'm
doing this i just want to feel better
about myself
what should i do thanks for your help uh
all right back up for a second
you said your wife is self-conscious and
you're worried that on a small level she
thinks the new me will be more
attractive and warrant the attention of
more females
as much as you say this isn't why you're
doing this i think that's why you're
doing it
subconsciously you know
i think that that's your thought and
you're putting it on your wife
you have to understand you understand
this all right your nose
all right that's like the uh that's the
hub of your face
okay if you add or subtract to that
you're really changing what you look
like
okay and every chick out there saw dirty
dancing
and they also at the lead of that movie
did she got a nose job
and i thought she was [ __ ] adorable
in that movie i thought she was
beautiful
you know i never i could never get
through the [ __ ] movie
but uh i thought she was hot and then
she got her nose job and i it was like
ah what did you do
you know look dude your [ __ ] nose
makes you
unique that's you should stick with it
stay with the i mean i don't know
to get a nose job because people teased
you when you were 14
you're better than that all right and
you're with your wife she loves you for
who you are
you know i i um
listen dude i mean it's your it's your
call in the end
but they don't exactly have those things
down to a science
you know what i mean at this point
plastic surgery it's like
shooting threes you know most of them
uh and most of them don't go in
[Laughter]
but when they do the crowd goes crazy so
there's a chance
that you could come out with the nose
you want but more times than not i think
it's gonna
if you know you want your nose to
[ __ ] clang off the front of the rim
or even worse
shoot a [ __ ] air ball and splat on
the [ __ ] hardwood
um i would never recommend
plastic surgery but dude i know what
you're uh i know what you're going
through this [ __ ] about myself i don't
like that i'm [ __ ] losing my hair
and believe me every time those hair
commercials come on i [ __ ] sit there
and look at them go should i
should i and then i always say i'm not
gonna but i never rule it out that i
wouldn't do it
i just keep waiting because every five
years it gets better and better and
better like how it looks
at this point now they can just vacuum
the hair out of the back and just
[ __ ] plant it up front um
as opposed to having the scars and the
hair plugs and having that [ __ ] them but
i i still for some reason
i'm not gonna do it um
i don't know why and i don't know why
i think about it because i think like i
can guarantee you this if women went
bald
they would all get [ __ ] hair they
would all have hair plugs in one
generation and then they would all have
that type of thing and always makes me
laugh when women make fun of guys
that get like a hair transplant like oh
my god as they sit there wearing makeup
you know high heels on and everything
about them is to [ __ ] enhance
you know their looks
um but then also i get why they don't
like it
you know because i think what they're
attracted to is different obviously they
don't have some troll of a man
but uh i think that they they may sir
this might come back to you
they want you to be a [ __ ] man and be
comfortable with yourself go out there
and swing a goddamn axe and bring some
[ __ ]
lumber in for the fire you know
they don't want to sit there watching
you looking at yourself in the mirror
going
look at this look at my nose i just
don't like how my ears look
you know i don't know
i this this my advice would be i would
think long
and [ __ ] hard all right
and you told me to look at that picture
of like tesla and constantine however
the [ __ ] you say their names
uh why don't you go look up that chick
before and after who was in
uh dirty dancing which is an [ __ ]
thing for me to do because i'm sure she
had a lot of trauma over there now i'm
gonna [ __ ] restore the pot
um but yeah and then you you'll probably
be like well that was a nose job from
[ __ ] 23 years ago and i feel like
rolling the dice then by all means go
for it but uh why don't you do before
and after
take a picture your nose standing to the
side
like the mug shot photo give me a
forward and to the side
and then forward to the side in the end
and this is the deal if you give me a
before and i never get an after then i
know what happened
i'm trying to think what what was one of
the songs from dirty dancing
was that that oh i had the time of my
life
and i'm dancing with patrick swayze
he has really tight slacks
and his hair is done better than mine
outros how hardcore was patrick swayze
the guy had cancer he's like yeah i'm
still smoking go [ __ ] yourself that dude
went out like a man
you know he really did so did saddam
hussein
to take a total left-hand turn all right
i can tell you right now people about
ready to hang me
all right and i and i was i would
definitely
accept the hood please put the hood over
my face so you can't see me blubbering
inside of it he said no i don't want the
hood he stared down everybody was
talking [ __ ] air [ __ ] you go [ __ ]
yourself your mother's a [ __ ]
then they put the rope around his neck
and furthermore
i said your grandmother's mother's a
[ __ ] i spit on you
and that was it
um all right outros oh here's the outros
here all right i guess the show is over
once again everybody a couple of things
if you'd like to buy a hard copy
version of my dvd for your old school
people you can now do that at
billberg.com you can also download it
um or you can come out to one of my
shows and i'll autograph it for you
um yeah and if you'd like to donate to
this podcast and the wounded warrior
project
go to amazon.com no go to the amazon.com
banner on the podcast page of my website
click on the son of a [ __ ]
go to amazon buy whatever the hell you
want doesn't change the price they kick
me a little uh
thanks for sending them here and then i
pass it on some of it
ten percent of it on to uh the wounded
warriors project
all right so that's it
okay now that the show's over don't
forget us to uh support our sponsors
go to uh go to set up the free trial of
e-voice join thousands of entrepreneurs
who use their e-voice personal
receptionist 24-7 right now get e-voice
for 30 days go to evoice.com promo code
bill that's evoice.com promo code bill
um and hulu plus as i mentioned start
watching tv
your favorite shows right now go to the
podcast page at billboard.com click on
the hulu plus banner for your extended
free trial
or huluplus.com bill and finally
sign up for dollar shave club forward
slash burr
makes a great father's day gift you get
high quality razors sent to your door
every month for a fraction of the cost
um and that is it ladies and gentlemen
that is it that is the podcast for this
week please watch the stanley cup finals
if you get a chance
also i'm rooting for the spurs i'm
rooting for the spurs against the miami
heat
i'm doing that you got to do it okay
you got to do it fundamental basketball
you know every white guy wants that to
win
you know because that's the best we can
bring fundamental basketball
there's never been a white dr j it just
has it you know there's been some white
guys we can grow afros
there's been a couple of white guys that
you know can jump a little bit but it's
just you know
we're pick and roll guys
so um who knows i don't know what's
going to happen uh
i think the inevitable but i'm hoping
the spurs are going to win
um and not even because that silly [ __ ]
that i was just saying about white guy
basketball i just love
you know you got to love when the
underdog wins and speaking of which the
bruins have got to be the underdog
against the uh the blackhawks
considering the first two games are in
chicago
isn't that right um who knows check it
out or
go check out sports illustrated read up
on some hockey can maybe you can get
involved in this series it's a great
game
that's it that's the podcast go [ __ ]
yourselves i'll talk to you next week
you